you
[Music]
so I'm going to talk about a proposal
for pass to AI and a bit of an
architecture perhaps and it will address
some of the issues of say ICT and things
like that but not too much so how can we
use the intelligence and dedication same
time basically how do they you know how
do we build until they do what we want
and you know we probably want them to be
more learn more more like Threepio than
Hal 9000 it is a collision of the two
worlds here and so I'm going to start
right away by kind of posting the
architecture of an AI system so this is
nothing particularly new here but any AI
agent or any IT system is composed of
essentially three basic modules when
it's a perceptual module that
essentially allows the agent to estimate
the state of the world another one is
the agent itself which basically
generates actions so action sequences
that are going to act on the world and
the agent has an internal state this
internal state goes into some sort of
objectives that kind of hardwired
through if you want built into the BI
system and basically tell the system
whether is happy or not think of it as a
cost and objective you want to minimize
and one of the things I'm going to I'm
going to say is that the agent will have
to be able to do prediction essentially
to be able to do anything intelligence
that will allow it to do planning
reasoning working have a working memory
for to enable it to do a lot of things
and the objective will drive the agent
to do things that we wanted to do and it
will be composed of two components so
one component is immutable and hardwired
and it's basically a safeguard
if the instincts of the machine if you
want that so it makes it but it'll do
things that we think are good and then
there's another component which is
trainable and I'll come back to this you
know in a minute so what are the
obstacles to AI wave or I think what's
the biggest obstacle that that I see
this is a very personal view and how
could the Xin acquire common sense which
is kind of
one of the Holy Grails of AI that say AI
has never been able to reach and the
short story is that he's not have common
sense and two queried the mostrar and
how the world worked by adoration and by
action and predictive running is kind of
the the solution to it so all of the
successes that we've had with AI today
are basically the result of supervised
running we can you know label images we
can drive cars you can do all kinds of
things that's basically all supervised
learning there's been some successful
reformate running that's always in a
virtual environment or in environments
where the direction is such that you can
have the equivalent of a very large
number child you know supervised running
is really insufficient for for real AI
and you can look at the animal world or
or humans
most of what we learn we learn in the
first few hours days months years of
life by basically observing the world
and acting in it and not being
necessarily told the name of everything
animal certainly don't learn this way so
you know we learned very basic things
like object permanence the fact that
when an object is hidden behind another
one is still there the fact that when an
object is not supported its false where
she'll only have babies between the age
of six and eight months roughly you know
there's a lot of kind of because trains
of the world that we learn by just
observing and that kind of builds allows
us to build a eternal model of the world
and we can use this model for prediction
that's kind of a critical aspect of it
and it's a massive amount of information
about the world that allows us to build
common sense so common sense that allows
us to do things like you know figure out
the the vision acuity in things like
winogradsky males sentences like the
turkey doesn't fit in the suitcase
because it's too large all the torpedoes
fit in the suitcase because it's too
small in the first case it refers to the
trophy in the second one to refers to
the suitcase and we can figure this out
because we know how to our work or we
can also fill in the blanks so if I say
a short sentence like my picked up this
bag and after room is all kinds of
events that you can infer that have to
happen as a consequence of the
description in the world because
you know all the constraints of the
world that the world has to satisfy so
how do we get machines to learned it so
common sense you could think of it as
the ability to fill in the blanks which
includes a further state of the world
from partial information predict the
future from the past in the present
predict the past from the present that's
useful if you're a police inspector or
if you want to figure out how someone
arrived at a particular goal and we do
this all the time your brain does this
all the time we have a black spot in our
retina and we're not conscious of it
because the brain can filled it up we we
can figure out you know you might only
see my left profile but you can figure
out what the right the white one looks
like more or less because most people
are symmetric so all kinds of things of
this type that we can predict and
basically or-or-or brains are prediction
engines and in fact you could say that
prediction is the essence of
intelligence really so the necessity of
unsupervised learning or those filling
in the blanks of predictive running is a
team that has been recurring in machine
learning for a very very long time by a
few people at least Clinton has been
sort of a big advocate for this for the
last thirty years or so
if not more in fact more like 40 but
using supervised running is not enough
it's just not enough knowledge that's
embedded in in sort of labeled data for
machines to really uncommon sense so in
fact you can sort of estimate really how
much information you give to the machine
when you ask you to predict different
types of data so in reinforcement
running pretty much the only thing you
ask the machine to predict or the only
information you give that to the machine
for to let it predict is just a few bit
once in a while basically you tell it
whether it did right or or where they'd
go too bad
that's a reinforcement value you'll tell
you what the correct answer is and so
the amount of information you ask it to
to predict and for which you give it the
answer is extremely small and the result
is that the sample complexity is
ridiculously large it means you need a
very very very large number of samples
for the pure RL system to learn anything
which is why only works in the actual
environment but it does work very well
in virtual environments
supervisor on you you give a little more
information to the Machine you tell you
for the correct answer is an
unsupervised rounding said in those
terms is kind of a critical grounding is
you you ask the machine to predict any
part of the data it's not seeing from
any part that it sees and eventually is
going to see the part that it's not
seeing at the moment and that it will be
able to adjust and
and and connect and and that may consist
of millions of millions of bits at every
trial and so that that's the necessity
for the training sufficiently many
parameters in a large intelligent system
so that is me to this slightly obnoxious
analogy that you know pure reinforcement
running is kind of a cherry on the cake
where supervisor on is the icing on the
cake and unsupervised addictive lowing
industry the bulk of the cake division
was at the same time right and so
integral is running unfortunately we
don't really know how to do properly so
it's like the dark matter of dark energy
rather of a I it's like it's dark on the
topside cake I should point out that
I've been showing this picture now for
about a year or so and this is a a black
forest cake and back for it cake has to
have a cherry on it
all right the cherry is not optional in
fact you know this is not a job against
RL because you know we work it out we
work on reinforcement running at fair
but model free RL working games but it
doesn't really work into very well
because you can't just you know the
business the main issue with the real
world is that you cannot run it faster
than real time and so you can't generate
lots of examples so here is a here is a
partial hit to a solution a that comes
from a rich Sutton's with here in the
audience somewhere and he said he
proposed his small local diner many
years ago 25 years ago and said the men
idea of Dyna is that the old common
sense idea the planning is trying things
in your head using an internal model of
the world this suggests the existence of
more primitive process for trying things
not in your head the through direct
interaction with the world we first met
Ronnie is the name we use for this more
primitive direct kind of training and
Donna is the expansion of reinforcement
wanting to include a loanword model
that that's what I mean by that what we
should do in some context this is called
model-based reinforcement running but
you don't have to have reinforcement
running for it it can be actually
supervised but the point is you have a
model of the world that predicts things
you don't observe so this is actually a
very classical way of handling planning
and in control theory where you have a
simulator for whatever system you want
to to control and and then you have an
objective to minimize and you kind of
choose the sequence of commands that
will optimize this dis objective and but
you need this time simulator if you want
to be able to do this so again the
architecture of an intelligent agent is
kind of what I showed at the beginning
and it really sort of mimics a little
bit how the brain is architected a
little bit in a piece conceptual view
another question we can ask is what is
in the inside of the agent and what's
inside the agent is inside the agent you
have to have this world simulator that
predicts what's going to happen in the
world just because the world is being
the world or because as the consequences
as the consequence of the actions of the
the agent inside the entrance you have
what I call an actor which is service
standard name for this in RL as well
which is sort of a module that generates
action proposals that are sent to the
wall simulator to see what the effects
of them would be and then there's a
critic which is basically a predictor
for how the objective function is going
to end up where it's going to end up if
you if you do this sequence so it's sort
of a trainable part if you want to try
to kind of predict the sort of long-term
expected reward if you want so we know
how to build pretty much all those
things we can do perception pretty well
you know the actor and the critic and
the reinforcement running side things
that are done for this are relatively
well understood but what we don't know
how to do is the wall simulator so in a
typical run the system would get a per
set and then generate the sequence of
action proposed the proposal run the
walk simulator to see what the result is
measure the expected error using the
critic and then adjust the
sequence of action proposals we can
optimize it and then sort of 20 self to
produce it directly at some goodbye so
here's the big problem how do we learn
20 click models of the world there's
number of experiments that have been
done at in various places interested in
bounds lab at MIT for example at his
books by some of my colleagues Adam
there are some goats and were progress
on sort of learning qualitative physics
or intuitive physics by kind of training
a convolutional net essentially to
predict what's going to happen next in a
simple kind of physical situation
training it's using 3d game engines so
for example predicting where virtual
blocks are going to fall etc and it
works decently well but the question is
you know how do we make this kind of
more general so for example how do we
train a system to project video what's
going to happen in the video that has in
a few frames maybe a seconds a minute or
an hour from now and if you do not eve
predictive running using the same
techniques that you use for supervised
running so take a commercial net for
example look at a few frames and then
have it generates the next frame or the
next few frames and then 22-degree
square what you get is predictions of
the site you see over on the left where
it's very blurry and it's very blurry
because there is no way you can put it
exactly what's going to happen in the
world so the best is the best the system
can do in a kind of a supervised
framework is to basically predict on
average of all the possible things that
could possibly happen and what you get
is a blurry image so we need better
method and I'm going to make a proposal
for this or to kind of explain the
difficulty of this basically we need a
new paradigm or formalism that would
allow us to train a predictor in such a
way that what it observes in the world
is not the correct answer but is one
representative of a whole set of
possible correct answers so for example
if I put a pen on a table and I let it
go it might fall in one direction or the
other is very difficult to predict in
which direction is going to fall but you
can predict it's gonna fall that's
pretty sure and so the the world is
telling us this point which is on a
manifold of possibilities and the system
is predicting this which is also
nominate for the possibility we don't
want to punish it for making the one
prediction as long as it
many photos possibility so in that
question you have to ask is what is this
many folders part of possible futures
come from comes from and we have to run
it and so the best idea for doing this
is an idea that popped up in your
ventures lab a couple years ago by Iain
good fellow who is also somewhere in the
room what if she was yesterday here is
and I've said this multiple times I
going to repeat it I think it's the best
coolest idea in machine learning in the
last 10 or 20 years and it's called
advertorial training
Ian called is generative a social
network and the basic idea of it is a
kind of a simplified fashion is that you
you take the you know a few frames home
video let's say I knew you're going to
train a generator this green box at the
bottom to predict the next frame the
next cue frame and there could be
another network and this network is
going to be this the the network that
tells you whether the point that's being
predicted is on the manifold
plausibility or outside of it okay so
it's basically a function a contract
function that produces a single scalar
value you give it a prediction one of
those points and he tells you you are a
very folder called plausible predictions
or you're not and of course this thing
is going to be a train simultaneously
with the generator and the way strange
is that you show it real-world
occurrences and predictions from the
generator and you train it to
discriminate between the two so the real
world things are the route beads you try
need to produce a low output for that
and then the generated samples those who
put the prediction by the generator
about green bead and you tell it
give give a high value to this a high
cost if you want to this and
seven-thirty see the general trend
itself to get the green points as close
as possible to the area where the
discriminator gives low cost so
eventually you get this where you get a
contrast function which is the
discriminative function and the
generator trains itself to produce
points that are in the values of that
function and I think it's very cool idea
it breaks everything that you know all
the theories that we're done with the
chignon in the past because they all
assume that we really need minimizing a
function and here
we're doing is finding a Nash
equilibrium between two functions it's
very weird mathematically but but it it
produces amazing result so these are
just completely generated images from
random vectors to train on imagenet
completely unconditionally and it looks
like you know if you're on the back of
the room the lookk reasonable if you're
on the front of the room you say whether
hell is this because there is no actual
recognizable object you can you can see
here but the statistics are correct this
is if you train on dog
you get Salvador Dali dogs or something
like that
no kind of soft dogs so this is a lot
progress being made very quickly in
those techniques these are relatively
high resolution images this is the first
time people have generated images of
this resolution 62-56 is again your I
show showed some results yesterday of
another technique that uses that retro
training but with another trick that
also generates nice pictures there's a
lot of work in this area
it's not funny truly exciting and I
actually know taking off like wildfire
in the community these are examples of
video prediction so on the top right is
what I showed earlier it's what you get
when you train a large commercial net to
predict the next couple of frames in a
video using a square a-square criterion
so just you know get it close as
possible to the to the real the real
thing and you get a very prediction and
the six other segments are predictions
using
advertorial training so the first four
frames observed are real friends and
then the last two frames which are so
called in in red are generated and it's
kind of decent continuation of the
motions that you deserve in the initial
four frames these are just two frame
prediction this is another one with five
frame prediction and here the task is we
train the system with videos of you know
someone kind of running around with a
camera in various apartments in New York
City and and we we try to system to
predict the next the next two friends
and here this is our example with the
camera pan and so what the system has to
do basically is invent what the
apartment looks like in places you know
after you know as the camera continues
tanning and you know it's not between
the department before so it's got a
cigarette you know how to continue the
aspect to the apartment one good example
for is is this one for example so it has
to kind of dream up with the you know
what the book the book pages look like
or what this library looks like as the
camera panned so it works for five
frames
doesn't quite work for 50 frames it gets
be great pretty quickly pretty pretty
badly you know it gets like really soft
so the real challenge they are is how do
we design sort of hierarchical versions
of this they can do prediction at
long-term that can make sense so we're
working on now back to the question of
how do we design honey function Jenna
okay so that's my pretty much my life
like so second right um so the the way
we would design the AI system to do to
do what we want and align its value to
ours these two ways when we can hardwire
a safeguard objective function or maybe
you know built-in instinct if you want
that that will get the machine to by
default beauty social etc to do what we
want but then there's a 20 volt part
because as a tour said yes that's what
Russell said yesterday it's very
difficult to actually kind of design an
objective function and be sure there is
no bad side effect so we should be able
to train the system also to kind of
trainees objective function and the 20
objective function is exactly what our
vests are your training is doing so in
fact there is a way to use that whether
you're training to train the objective
function by what's called inverse
reinforcement learning or imitation
learning where basically the objective
gets the action for particular context
from the human trainer as well as from
the agent and basically trains itself to
discriminate between the two and the
agent can arrange itself to make its
action
indistinguishable from the trainer as
possible and then eventually will arrive
this objective function that basically
relates to objective function of the
trainer so we have technical solutions
to this for once I agree with tort so
thank you very much
Thank You Andrew Maynard with this
adversarial training approach do you
always get exactly the same output for
the same input or is the some degree of
variation that that sort of projects
different possible imagined futures so
really what the generator is is a
parameter ization of this manifold of
possibility and so there are there are
the way you generate different points on
this manifold is that you pick different
values of kind of a latent variable that
is called V in this case which you can
see as a set of parameters that
parameterize the surface in the training
during training those are children
randomly but there are other techniques
that people using Auto is not random
jörgen young Schmitt over from the Swiss
a I lab I agree with much what you said
there and I see a problem however if you
want to apply that to real world
settings when you are trying to simulate
the world is essentially because what
you are trying usually is to simulate at
millisecond by millisecond so you ask
this recurrent in your network which is
the controller which they expend all the
data and then it translates it into
action sequences and it has this little
friend which is the anti-vice model
which does the predictions and wants to
become a better predictor and then you
use this planner to plan into the future
and then select action sequences but
lead to situations with high predicted
reward according to this one model and
this is basically what what we published
in 25 years ago within actually one
Brunelleschi's right it's classical I
mean I really don't but not which we can
your networks and and then it's a
problem of classes if you want to have a
sequence that spans a long time like for
example going from here to Beijing you
don't want to simulate that millisecond
by millisecond instead you want to
figure out these relevant sub goals so
you first go to the taxi station then
you go to the to the airport and so on
and for a long time nothing happened and
now I think there are much better ways
of exploring on exploiting this
knowledge in the prediction machine
which
to requires with millisecond by
millisecond I never advocated me like
I'm going on second you know I mean I
totally agree that the prediction should
have multiple times can you can learn it
that's a good thing and should be
hierarchical and should should be
learned yes there's no we completely
agree on
[Applause]
[Music]